So, my science is basic science
and what that means is that i'm finding out
how something works at a very fundamental level.
You know the physiology of it, the morphology of it,
the mechanics of it.
Whether it ends up at some point in time
helping to solve a problem? We don't know.
Maybe. Maybe not. But what it does
is that it contributes to this base of knowledge
that we have without which we
would not be able to solve problems at all.
OK, so science is not a linear process
it's not that if I want to cure cancer
you know the easiest way is to start from
A to B to Z.  It doesn't work that way.
You need to have people who are having a
very broad base you know people who are
coming at it from different ways asking
different questions and then somebody
else comes in and they make an
unexpected connection.
And as you build on that eventually you know
somebody comes up and they're like:  "Oh yeah
this therapy that they're using
for something totally unrelatable
might be the key to study this question."
And that's just how it goes and so without
that broad base of knowledge the tip of the iceberg,
which is finding those applications,
would just simply go away.
And so we can't pick and choose from the beginning
and say: "Well, we're only going to study things
that we know are going to have some benefits.
Because we don't know.
We don't know what we don't know.
That's the whole point.
That's the whole point of science.
And in the meantime we're pushing the boundaries
of our knowledge and just figuring out, okay,
so then how do things work you know?
And that's important.
It's an important part of what makes us human i think.